[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ma été nous avons une
bien belle bête devant nous lou ye c'est
un chapeau c'est un beau chapeau et
qu'allons nous faire avec ce chapeau
eh bien on va faire un chapon cuit à la
broche et farci au foie gras
alors que nous faudra-t-il c'est la
question traditionnelle pour faire un
chapon farci au foie gras est cuit à la
broche et bien il ne faut pas mal de
choses c'est à dire de l'armagnac du
jambon du bon jambon un joli fois grave
à foie gras je vous arrête tout de suite
un x recrues un fois plusieurs fois
frais on appelle de cannes à vous de
voir nous on fait avec du foie de canard
parce que bon moi j'ai pas doigts j'ai
besoin je fais avec du foie de canard
qui est excellent et vous trouvez groupe
lui faire revivre après une photo
l'oignon et fodé laye il faut des
échalotes de la grèce du peur et puis là
il faut pas mal de petites choses passer
après mais c'est pour le la compagne de
l'accompagnement de nos viendra d'abord
le chapeau oui tout le monde connaît le
nous on en parle beaucoup dans les
livres alexandre dumas parle tout le
temps du chapeau mais quelle différence
en fait entre un chapeau et un poulet à
ça c'est une histoire alors en chapons
c'est un groupe où les camps châtre à la
naissance
oui c'est à dire que qu'est-ce qu'on
s'inquiétait un bon écoutez moi je vous
dis aux commandes comme je dis on lui
enlève les cocottes et coco et puis
voilà
et c'est tout bonnement ça rend le char
c'est très douloureux ça fait très mal
mais ça fait devenir une bête tels que
c'est est alors en série et large de
plus fait un petit tout petit tout petit
ou alors ils seront pas trop content que
ça leur selon nous sape et c'est ça qui
le fait devenir beaucoup plus gros
couple ah oui oui oui
alors pour l'accompagner tout à l'heure
nous ferons vous m'avez dit des pommes
dauphines
oui les pommes dauphine où l'on trouve
partout dans les supermarchés nous nous
allons les faire réellement comme il
faut les faire
on commence par l'as far oui alors j'ai
pris un peu d'avancé mais jamais de
l'hogneau on va finir un petit peu
d'échalotes il faudrait en plus de gens
bon j'en avais déjà mais il faut
peut-être mettre un peu plus voilà le
genre bord de carrière ça y est ensuite
je prends que vous m'avez dit qu'il
fallait mettre
oui la grèce a chauffé pendant ce temps
mon nom la poêle pendant que je suis
tourné là et après on va la faire
revenir un tout petit peu cette farce
parce que le chapon et gros wade n 2
cuillerées pas bien dans ce chantier je
me demande si je me souviens pas que
vous aviez dit que la sorte voulu métier
quelque chose en plus de l'armagnac mais
voilà pourquoi la halle on peut y aller
moi j'ai fini là c'est bon oui c'est bon
voilà la raison de notre petit saladier
que voici
et on va bientôt d'autres soupçons
d'armagnac parce que là vous savez on
peut en mettre et on peut en mettre 2 ne
faut pas faut pas exagérer mais mais
j'aime messi comme une idée de remettre
ça va mal entendu la chanson ça ne gâche
pas très sympa c'est raisonnable et tout
ça on le met immédiatement à accueillir
à revenir laisse lire vous dites même
non non non mais revenir un peu revenir
un peu sur la ferveur des 28 heures la
foule voilà bel effet pour la surveiller
oui euh là et moi je vais mettre coup
fumant foie gras en b je vous laisse la
place
allez-y oui par qui la composent à
surveiller pour que ça revienne et que
ça ne brûle parfois pas de sel non le
limbourg sa bonté sa maman et moi
maintenant je vais faire mon foie gras
il ne faut pas des marseillais l'a
prouvé et pourquoi est ce que vous ne
mettez pas la farce cru
non parce que le chapon est gros et
l'intérieur ça n'est pire est passé je
ne paierai pas dans sa personne et on
n'envoie oui quand vous y êtes mon avis
oui oui je vais me votre humour gras il
est bien pas encore pas encore non je te
va si vite - oui si ça va très bien
quelques petits morceaux
c'est dommage on va remettre dans le
saladier la farce oui la ferme et aimons
tous la main voilà c'est parfait ça
c'est bien bon il faut pas gaspiller
alors là vous mettez le foie cru quand
la farce chaud dans la farce chaude et
alors quand on a la chance mais nous ne
l'avons pas quand on a la chance d'avoir
même ne serait ce que des brisures de
truffe et bien ça me gâche rien
oh oui on les a ajouté oui on les ajoute
à la remet ça dans la farce et je vous
assure ça donne un gentil petit parfum
aussi alors là on n'a pas vidé notre foi
on va le faire
notre chapeau très bien eh bien on va le
remplir de notre bord de farce
voilà on va pousser et après on va la
coudre et on va nous avons approché le
faire cuire à notre charmant de cheminée
alors ce chapeau bien sâr si il faut le
coudre bien entendu les ensuite pour que
la farce ne sortent pas à la cuisson
bien sûr on va vous arriver au bout là
je crois que j'ai presque fermé voilà
très soigneusement respect surtout parce
qu on le cuit à la broche et voir
toujours s'impliquer quand on fait
quelque chose mais je vous passez la
brosse si j'ai bien compris mme oui par
quel bout vous allez leur rocher à on va
dire bon lui couper la tête
ah oui parce que la tête le jeune avait
évidemment on va lui couper la tête qui
se trouve à petit et voilà
et voilà les ailes sont bien mises et
bien voilà brochet voilà la broche
oui par le derrière toujours toujours là
ça passe tout seul
voilà on va faire voilà l'autre bout
pour bien figurez vous
parfaire fabien serré bien wc a
l'impression qu'on est encore au temps
des mousquetaires et voilà et bien voilà
on va le faire cuire et ben ça y est
mais on va de salles et le poivre et
bien sûr avant de le cuire
oui assez généreuse j'aurais dû le faire
avant de mettre la branche sales et pas
à l'intérieur
non non j'en bord non non c'est pas la
peine parce que les gens moi je suis
finalement ils n'ont recruté par ed
tsahal et le poivre et il faut sans
regret 'j'en ai rien on ne va pas il ne
faut pas regretter parce que quand la
rosa sa part ses 120 peux vous dire tout
ça n'est jamais trop en métro et mais
non pour ce qu'il faut quand même il
faut ce qu'il faut surtout qu'il va
cuire très longtemps lui amenant la wii
les gourous la regardez moi pas trop
très joli très très bien voilà on a plus
que le travail à faire plus important je
vais me tourner voilà et vous allez
mettre sur la branche oui ça c'est le
plus dur parce qu'il faut que je me
trouve le petit round bravo ça y est là
je pense que c'est la voie la grand-mère
de la lèche je suis pour le but
et puis le petit engrenage qui dans
cette machine va former médias joliment
bien tranquillement sur faut compter
combien de temps pour un beau chapeau
comme ça bien plus d'une heure est bien
plus bien plus d'une heure et à vous la
route et de temps en temps ou bien vous
ajoutez de la grèce qu'est ce que vous
faites rien de temps on va l'annoncer
avec notre concurrent à la fin la crise
voilà la fin de la cuisson on mettra
notre la wii et on arrosera enverra
d'autant leur parce que pour le moment
il n'en a pas besoin
valletoux je n'y a pas de toucher avec à
si long temps de cuisson je crois que
nous allons avoir largement le temps de
préparer l'accompagnement la campagne
met à lire des pommes de l'hebdo fils
bien sûr et comment les faits tôt c'est
pas difficile il faut tout d'abord
mettre un demi litre d'eau parce que ça
dépend des quantités comment faire nous
on n'est pas malheureux
alors va mettre en å ministre de rendre
des amis oui un ministre c'est ça on met
un demi litre d'eau là à changer oui du
sport havrin oui bien entendu du sel oui
voilà
parce que ça le père ne pouvons pas les
pauvres dauphine a pris 7
on va mettre dedans 125 g de beurre oui
laure 125 g de beurre c'est à peu près
ça ou bien sûr c'est que petit plat oui
une rangée de plaques de beurre quand le
beurre est fondu ça va la vivre très
vite on y jette dedans
300 g de farine ça va faire deux
immigrés ou pas du tout pas du tout mal
du tout non d'eau en jetant dans l'eau
bouillante
oui vous allez voir pas du tout c'est
comme la pâte à chou c'est la pâte à
choux seulement installer volandri
oui et les saler poivrer c'est tout mais
ce seuil a pas de miracle la voilà on va
bien faire fondre ça là on y met notre
tâche seul coup d'un seul d'un seul coup
c'est l'heure parce que c'est là que
vont être énergique un petit peu il faut
bien voilà et oui des bombes rang et
bien tournée le reste le carré est ainsi
qu est ce que vous allez faire pour s'en
tirer à vous allez me casser les oeufs
vous me passez les au oui on va casser
les oeufs de dames deux par deux mais là
il faut que la pâte lafarie de ce décor
au fond de la casserole
ah oui à voir mais le réseau et graff
avoir la regarder à se décoller la fosse
et sheila pas tout à sécher la patte
avant de la regarder à elle vient tout
seul bien sûr la voilà c'est terminé
ils sont pas deux heures et dix vous
voulez casser et là c'est là qu'il faut
faire et vite au moins pour les premiers
parce qu'il faut pas les brûler les yeux
et dans la pâte les bouillantes et ont
revu je continue non non non non non il
faut que cela ait absorbé deux par deux
mais jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient bien y
amener à l'impôt mettre les autres début
qu'il faut faire attention pour que
cette mélange bien oui oui oui voilà et
là vous n'avez pas loupé les balles
quand cette base de pâte à choux est
terminée vous ajoutez des promotions de
thèmes il n'en faut pas beaucoup et oui
mais attendez elles sont pas cru là vous
les 1,48 sont cuites à l'eau mais il ne
faut pas la faire la paix avec du beurre
individus tous que la pomme de terre
sont de la pomme de terre que l'entente
de terre seulement et après il n'en faut
pas beaucoup par exemple pour un 2009
ont encore un peu plus tard un train
entre les deux
deux forums demi litre d'eau oui il faut
à peu près deux jolies pour le terrain
comme ça ça y est on a demandé ça y est
je vous enlève les yeux vous m'aimez pas
je sais voilà pendant ce temps les
petits grésillement derrière nous qui
sont pas antipathique
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est notre
champion qui continue affirmant je vais
faire tourner on va commencer à prendre
une jolie couleur oui voilà ça c'est ici
là c'est bon c'est bon c'est moyen assez
et que vous allez faire maintenant elle
est mélangée ça alors je vais nettoyer
et tout y est moi je parle massa sur ces
gars cossart exactement la valeur nommé
large mais délicatement pour pas fait
c'est l'art de faire il faut faire
doucement
oui et voilà et on va s'approcher de
votre ville oui qui est en train de
chauffer alors l'huile il faut que ce
soit sur deux oui mais pas quand même
fumantes brûlante là je crois que le
free sur un petit peu et les comme il
faut et oui parce qu'il va falloir
imagine que ça gonfle à ce qu'attend
donc il faut que ça gonfle oui c'est
pour ça que vous la tournée en
incorporant de l'air
voilà voilà voilà alors là pour le gore
fait il ya un petit truc un petit secret
on à la pomme de terre
il faut prendre une cuillère à l'appui
la réforme dauphine vous prenez la pâte
comme ça et après vous trompez ce la
cuillère propre dans l'huile là et vous
la mettez comme ça et vous retrouvez
votre cuillère est toujours propre et
vous faites les petites pommes dauphines
n'essayez pas de faire des grosses
boules parce que vous ne gagnerez pas
elles sont des normes seront pleines et
ne sont pas bonnes
alors il faut les faire petit et nous
avec une bonne astuce que je ne
connaissais pas parce qu'on l'a toujours
de la pâte à choux qui reste sur la
cuillère non mais voilà voilà que vous
ressentez aussitôt
et voilà et alors là c'est pareil même
opération les pommes dauphines il faut
les revues et oui contrairement à ce
qu'on croit pour qu'elle gonfle et
qu'elle sait qu'elle va comme les petits
beignets oui il aime tourner tout seul
et vous allez voir comment d'autres
belles redorer jolie et regarde elle
commence à rire tout seul là ça va
tourner tout seul
les pommes dauphines sont terminées
elles sont belles et rissoler oui toutes
légères est tout gonflé d'air assez bon
bien sûr comme des choux à la crème et
xavier un petit goût de pomme de terre
délicieux et ses salles et c'est simple
voie d'être con à voir ce qu'elle vient
de sa pompe pendant sept ans exactement
tournis tout lé bien sûr allons le voir
un petit peu on maïté qui les bouches
chapeau maintenir très joli il adore
rire les couleurs extraordinaires
il est tout à fait prêt non on va le
voir venir on va le finir aux
concurrents maintenant c'est à dire
c'est à dire voilà alors on va prendre
un autre petit concurrent
oui et puis on va y mettre notre grain
de jambon et puis ça y est sa seconde et
sa flamme et regardez le jus qui coule
ils sont là bien arrosée ça va bien
arroser ça va lui donner le goût du
jambon qui continue à tourner toute
votre mère de sa 7e confiante et puis
c'est pas dégueulasse comme on dit cela
donnait enfin de google à la jolie que
la biologie la en dessous et pourra
utiliser après oman le servira
magnifique
et puis si vous voulez essayer fr3
aquitaine désormais publie les recettes
de la cuisine des mousquetaires en
cassette vidéo vous pouvez les demander
et quant à nous maïté on continue voilà
on continue à bientôt à bientôt en
france et au revoir
[Musique]